bis zum 1 ich hoffe ich vielleicht nicht
für mich gewählt
das habe ich nicht erwartet
nur leid der film ja dann doch noch
überraschend den oscar für den besten
film gewann hat komplett englisch in die
deutschen kinos an einem bestimmten
punkt natürlich entscheiden würde sein
und wie man kann diese entscheidung
abnehmen mein absoluter liebling des
letzten jahres haben einen solchen film
noch nicht gesehen das kann ich wirklich
garantieren unser glück nicht nur daran
dass er fantastisch gespielt ist von
drei unterschiedlichen hauptdarsteller
in der hauptrolle wie will ich auch gar
nicht besonders ähnlich aber man spürt
doch dass das dieselbe figur es in all
age höher auf in meinem haus den kopf
hängen zu lassen
du kannst meine rede in diesem haus gibt
es nur liebe und stolz heißt immer es
ist eine art x3 einen stock in das
auslangen
das ist zwar so in gewisser weise ist
eine wirklich nur die hälfte der
wahrheit weil die linsen die in diesem
film im auto kommt eine ist die jetzt
nicht nur schwarz gültigen ein
universell gültig und wer sind sie
niemand will ihn vorgefunden
hamminkeln wie diese menschen und vieh
nur in dieser form noch nicht gesehen
ein drogen wieder der ein kind das
schwimmen beibringt mit einer
zärtlichkeit ich garantiere glaube ich
jeden der ein hartes die fsg mehr
erscheinen wird und fanden gegen
sentimentale verdrücken von drei eine
bei gerade die richtigen knöpfe gedruckt
wurden von dem verringern weil es
einfach so gut war es wärmer man spürt
die freiheit wieder
die dieses klingt erst mal erlebt im
wasser liegt und erhalten wird mensch
gebäudes mit freiheit und nun spielt er
war aktiv um haare vertrauen
[Musik]
entwicklung dieses jungen ist eine die
mich sehr stark davon bestimmt es dass
er als kind er es anders als die anlage
zeigt sich ein bisschen im rahmen
münchner wie er spricht am anfang ganz
schüchtern und erstes opfer von den
anlernen kindern halt die erfahrung
macht von wald und fingern großer
einsamkeit und am ende im letzten teil
und sich so ein kam mit solchen muskeln
und tun und er ist trotzdem so voll von
dieser sehnsucht nach einem vollen den
augen verloren hat dem einzigen mann mit
ihr zusammen bei der einzigen person mit
der rmc sexuell zusammen den christen
also ich hab dich eine ewigkeit nicht
wissen du trinkst ein mit der so anders
aussieht als alles was an hollywood bei
denen die figuren so anders in refrath
andere sind wie gestellt werden das den
großen preis gewann hat dass sie nicht
gleich ganz gut
du musst mich nicht
aber die sind alle die sich in vereinen
männer frauen halte junge schwarzwald
gelbes ganz egal alle seine reinigung
ich glaube alle werden mit dem gefühl
eine schönheit beigewohnt zu haben
daraus geht lange versuchte verkehren
die ganze zeit vergangen